this video is sponsored by skillshare in
the words of the late renowned author
kurt vonnegut to practice any art no
matter how well
or badly is a way to make your soul grow
so do it i believe the world would be a
better place if more people discovered
their own artistic nature
and fortunately for the world so does
skillshare it's a completely
online learning community with thousands
of classes specifically tailored to
unlock the creativity of the human soul
like one of my personal favorite classes
called find your style five exercises to
unlock your creative identity by andy j
pizza and for those who already know
what their creative identity is
there are tons more classes for stuff
like painting
taking pictures or even editing youtube
videos you name it and all of them are
completely
fun informative and free of any ads
the first 1 000 of my subscribers to
click the link in the description below
will get a free trial of skillshare's
premium membership
so if you want to watch your small steps
evolve into giant leaps
don't wait and now on to the video
hey everyone bandit here when the most
recent trailer for breath of the wild
sequel dropped
most fans and even the most elite of
theorists were left going
what the heck is that what's with this
thing what exactly is going on here
in summary what but that's exactly what
makes theorizing so much fun we were
able to see a lot of new things in the
trailer but also a lot of changes to the
world of hyrule that we already know of
from breath of the wild
which is exactly what i want to cover in
this video and like i said in the last
zelda video on the channel
this subject is way too big for one
person to cover alone so i've called in
a friend
please give it up for the one the only
the fabulous
nintendo black crisis hey guys it's will
jordan said i was allowed to say
whatever i wanted for an introduction
which to be honest isn't the smartest
thing to do
you don't just give me this level of
power without reaping the consequences
but unfortunately i couldn't think of
any good zonai puns to add in here
so i'm not gonna try and force it
get it triforce zelda okay
moving on i do want to quickly say that
my video is going to take
a bit longer to make so in the meantime
you'll have to deal with me here
well i did tell him to say whatever he
wanted and he definitely took that and
ran with it
anyway we've got a lot to cover here so
without further ado let's delve right in
to trying to explain all of the changes
we see to hyrule and its inhabitants in
the breath of the wild 2 trailer
to start off let's briefly list all the
differences that are shown to us in the
new trailer
beginning with the end of the trailer
and working backwards
why you ask i don't know that's just how
bandit scripted it
in the final shot we can see hyrule
field with the castle levitating in the
air due to ganondorf's handiwork
which is obviously the first major
difference from the original breath of
the wild
although in contrast with the original
trailer we can now see plenty of malice
emanating from beneath the castle
thanks to bandit's footage of the same
angles taken from the original game
we can immediately see that the giant
chica columns that were present
surrounding the castle in the first
game are completely missing in the
sequel the ridgeland shika tower
visible in the far distance is missing
as well
also there is a bokoblin skull present
in the bottom left corner of the frame
in the sequel
whereas previously there was no camp
skull located there
backing up to the shot of link fighting
some enemies on the terrain surrounding
death mountain
this particular angle doesn't show
enough of the world of hyrule to
accurately place its location
but we can already tell some differences
off the bat
regardless of where this scene is
specifically taking place
due to the characters we see moving
around here on the enemy side we can see
that maublins no longer have horns on
the tops of their heads
but now are shown to have some sort of
spiky bowler hat looking helmet that
they wear
the bokoblins horns are also longer and
feature even more spikes
on link's side we can see that he's
apparently somewhere in the death
mountain area
but unless he chugged a fireproof elixir
off-screen
he's not wearing any heat protection to
protect him from the intense heat of the
volcano
this may actually have an explanation
though
because if we rewind to the first scene
of hyrule in the trailer
the one that shows link gliding across
the screen with his new paraglider
we can see a lot of new details in the
distance
at the beginning of the shot we can see
that the pink leaves of the deku tree
that
should be visible on the horizon are
actually missing completely
but in its absence strange blocky rocks
are shown kind of sticking out of the
ground in the middle of the field
in addition we can again see that not
one
not two but three chica towers are
completely missing
including the akala tower which should
be extremely visible from this shot as
it's supposed to be sitting on top of
this summit
furthermore the two divine beasts
varudania and varuta
who sit atop death mountain in the
zoro's domain respectively
are also completely missing and speaking
of death mountain it appears that there
is no lava flowing from its peak anymore
there also appears to be some sort of
giant mass of
something positioned between these two
peaks here as the camera pans to the
right
it appears to possibly be one of the
floating islands in the sky
but we can't know for sure at this point
as far as the foreground of the scene
goes
in the original game there is a guardian
stalker here but no
stone talus enemy implying the bokoblins
that have now built a mobile base atop
the rock giant
may be able to pilot them around hyrule
at this point
and finally we once again see the
bokoblins themselves much more clearly
in the shot
complete with their lawn horned glory
wow
that sure was a lot shown in a less than
two minute trailer
in fact i bet there's enough there to
make like a 45 minute documentary about
it anyway let's start breaking down
these differences one by one and attempt
to explain all of them
going in reverse reverse order this time
because i said so the pcoblins or
eunuch goblins as i affectionately refer
to them as now sport a giant horn on top
of their heads but goblins have been
depicted with horns three times now in
skyward sword breath of the wild and now
the sequel to breath of the wild so the
horn itself is nothing new
but the fact that they're just so long
now is what's been bugging me ever since
the trailer dropped
however i think that we can tell with
some decent confidence exactly what it
means
some people have theorized that their
horns have grown longer because of the
influence of ganondorf being stronger
than ever
and that's even why they're shown to be
smarter this time around piloting stone
giants and whatnot but i don't think
this is the case because of the
different colored bokoblins from the
first game
which prove to us what happens when a
pokemon becomes severely influenced by
ganon's power
and it actually doesn't have anything to
do with the size of their horns
according to the hyrule compendium if
you read the entries for any of the
silver colored enemies in the game
you can see that they are the color
silver due to being influenced by
ganon's power the step up from these
enemies golden enemies
are said to have once been silver
enemies that were struck by lightning
and didn't die because of this but
rather transformed into golden enemies
i did a test on one of these golden guys
to see if lightning or electricity could
harm them and
yep test results came back positive so
in my opinion
the lightning they were struck by would
have to have been the malice lightning
shown to originate from the malice storm
that formed over hyrule castle when
calamity ganon rose once again
and i'd imagine malice lightning is
pretty concentrated so striking a silver
enemy with this kind
of lightning is probably what did the
trick and turn them into gold while also
not killing them
but no matter how much ganon influence
the bokoblins had in the first game the
size of their horns has always remained
the same from the lowly red all the way
up to the dreaded
golden which is why i am led to believe
that the bakoblin horns shown in the
trailer are not magical at all
which means that the only logical answer
is staring us in the face these
bokoblins
are just older they've lived longer and
have grown
and so have their horns which is what
horns do in real life for animals that
have horns
the thing is in order for this to happen
some sort of time lapse has to have
occurred between the events of the first
breath of the wild and the sequel
but since we see that all of the sheik
attack structures have been removed from
hyrule somehow there must have been at
least
some passage of time between the games
so i don't think that
older unicoblins is too far-fetched to
believe
there's also the fact that they are
being smarter and building mobile bases
these days and being smarter is supposed
to be a characteristic of getting older
as far as the moblins are concerned for
them to wear these spiky helmet things
they would have to have cut off their
horns from the first game which
i honestly have no clue why they'd do
maybe they naturally fall off after
getting too long
and their little spiky bowler hats are
to compensate for their balding i mean
who knows
maybe what we're looking at is a bunch
of balding mobbles
oh what i don't think anyone cares about
balding moblins
but i care about balding marblins
well balding moblins aside more
importantly let me just play devil's
advocate for a second
you said that the longer horned
bokoblins have just unicoblins
that the unicoblins have
just aged a bit since the first game but
what if the footage we see of hyrule is
actually from the distant past
like oh i don't know 10 000 years ago or
more
oh well actually i strongly disagree
with that statement and here's why
the last shot of hyrule that depicts the
floating castle shows us a hyrule that
is more or less the same as it was in
the first game
complete with the same various
structures such as this hylian brick
wall in ruins
logically speaking if this was the
hyrule from 10 000 or more years ago
that wall would either just not exist
yet or would not be in ruins to believe
that it could exist
this way that long ago is just illogical
also when we see link pulling a meteo
together through the ground of one of
the skyrule islands
the zoom out perspective from the camera
actually shows us present day hyrule
beneath skyrule which we know
is present day because we can see the
mushroom-like trees from the hyrule
ridge and even the windmills from the
tanagar canyon
the former of which would be smaller or
non-existent and the latter of which
would simply not exist yet if this were
the hyrule of ten thousand plus years
ago good points
there's also the akalo citadel present
in this shot but i think we've spent
long enough on this point
i second that get us back on track sir
moving on as i mentioned earlier
literally all of the shiga structures
have been removed from hyrule in the
sequel
at least as far as we can tell currently
i know some of you may be thinking that
it's just a matter of the game's
engine's draw distance not drawing in
the sheikah objects from this distance
but game developers have long since
gotten over that hindrance of bigger
objects that should be visible in the
distance of a game world by using
a low polygon duplicate object model
technique
in breath of the wild any object that's
large enough to be understandably
visible from a distance has a duplicate
low poly mesh that renders instead of
the high poly close-up mesh
this uses the same logic that the game
engine already uses to determine whether
or not to render grass or other smaller
objects and particles based on the
distance
from the individual objects and i'm
going over all of this to state that
unless breath of the wild 2 is somehow a
more poorly developed
game that runs worse than its
predecessor the only reason that the
sheikah structures are not present in
any of the scenes from this trailer
is not that the game engine can't handle
rendering them
but that they were removed by some force
in game
the question is what is that force in
the true ending of breath of the wild
zelda states that there has been a
malfunction with varuta
and that it has stopped working many
have theorized that this is because it
no longer had a purpose after ganon's
defeat
for the sake of time we won't be going
into that particular theory in this
video
but let's assume that this was true of
all the divine beasts following the
ending of breath of the wild
if this were the case it wouldn't be too
much of a stretch to say that the
remaining cheek attack that
also runs on ancient energy meaning the
towers and shrines as well
would also cease to function following
the defeat of calamity ganon
one might be tempted to disprove this by
bringing up the fact that the sheikah
slate is shown still being used by zelda
at the end of the game
but if you recall it was functional
before any of the other towers were at
the beginning of breath of the wild
so maybe it just has insanely good
battery life
back on topic though if the sheikah
structure stopped functioning after
ganon's defeat
then receding back into the ground from
whence they came initially
seems like something the sheikah could
easily have programmed into their
technology
in the case of it no longer being needed
this would automatically explain away
the lack of shika towers and pillars
seen in the trailer
but the divine beasts are a bit
different since they have
you know legs and stuff we don't have
much reason to believe that they would
bury themselves underground
so perhaps they were moved by something
instead could it be possible that the
princess
upon retaking the throne of hyrule and
rallying the hylians back to a unified
civilization
formulated a research team and slowly
but surely dismantled or just
moved the divine beasts for the purpose
of her research
that does seem in line with what zelda
was all about prior to the great
calamity
and with ganon's return being classified
as something that will always come back
given the passage of time it makes sense
that she'd still want to understand how
the shika weapons work
so she can render them useful for future
generations
very well put i think that wraps up the
missing chica tech very nicely now let's
talk about the missing pieces of nature
like the lava on death mountain or the
missing deku tree
as far as death mountain no longer
producing lava is concerned
that could simply be due to link having
calmed vardanya in the first game which
may have led to the volcano calming down
long enough to the point to where the
air is livable around it
like most of the dormant volcanoes in
our own real life world
as for the deku tree though the fact
that it's missing is very interesting
indeed
see we already went over how we know
this hyrule is present
future day hyrule and not the hyrule of
the past meaning it's not probable that
this is simply before the deku tree
sprouted fully
that means something moved it again
unless the draw distance is just really
really bad in the sequel as nintendo
black crisis mentioned in his analysis
video
ganondorf has a history of attacking the
deku tree actually in ocarina of time he
kills the deku tree since he's
apparently free now in breath of the
wild sequel
and since the deku tree now plays a
larger role than ever in guarding the
master sword itself as nintendo black
crisis stated ganondorf has
every reason to go after it but as he
also mentions it could also be missing
due to having risen into skyloft
possibly to escape from ganondorf's
attacks since we can't see very
clearly in that direction in the trailer
there's no way of telling whether it's
just the deku tree missing and the rest
of the korok forest is there or there's
now just a giant crater in the ground
where it all used to be but no matter
what we speculate it's always centered
around ganondorf's revival and his
probable assault on the deku tree
the last thing we'll cover in this
differences explained video are the
strange blocky rocks that are sticking
out of the ground in this shot
now personally i am a huge fan of the
notion that they are fallen blocks or
pillars from skyrule above
i mean they're new to this game and
their blocky design resembles the
pillars present in this dungeon that
link is rapidly trying to fill with fire
and the islands of skyrim are also
filled with blocky designs for the
grounds and buildings
given that they were not present in the
first game and they mimic the designs of
all the weird skyrule stuff in the
trailer
i'd say saying these blocks here are
fallen from skyro is about as clear-cut
as speculation as we can get what do you
think mr crisis
yeah i think we just about covered it
all well awesome and hey man thanks
again for helping out with this one
there's just
so many possibilities with everything
we've been shown and it really helped
that you were here thanks for having me
on again
i have to say that i'm very excited for
this game
quick reminder that the collaboration
over on my channel will be uploaded in a
couple days
so stay tuned for that we'll be talking
about who may have been responsible for
the sky ruins
now if you'll excuse me i think i just
saw a zona
swirl outside best of luck with checking
that out there man i wonder what he's
gonna think when he replays wind waker
and realizes that there's a green zone i
swirl
present every time a dialog box is open
anyway huge thanks to everyone for
watching and a humongous thanks to my
amazing bandit crew who are the
reason that i can make these videos with
the amazing people that i make them with
if you watching are interested in
getting your name up here having a hand
in making these videos
and helping me buy chicken nuggies for
my tummies then please feel free to
click that join button below or follow
the links in my description for my
patreon and merch pages
also down there are the links to my
social media pages so come follow me on
instagram for some random nuggets of
happiness and geeky zelda stuff
or you know just whatever i feel like as
always i hope you have a wonderful rest
of your day
this is mass intended bandit signing out
and looking forward to seeing you in the
next one
[Music]
you